[MUSIC PLAYING]
JON FOUST: Hi, and
welcome to episode 179
of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
I am John Foust, and I'm here
with my colleague and friend
Mark Mirchandani.
Hi, Mark.
How's it going?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Hey, Jon, I'm so
glad that you called
me your friend as well
as your colleague.
[JON CHUCKLING]
You know what, you're
my friend, too, Jon.
JON FOUST: I mean,
we did share a car
ride playing Super Smash
Bros during Google I/O.
So I'm pretty sure we're
really good friends.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That was
one of the-- the most fun Uber
ride I may have ever had.
But that was a lot
of fun, you know,
to kind of take some downtime.
Because that event was--
woo, that was a lot.
And it was kind of nice
just to spend 30 minutes--
I mean, admittedly we
were stuck in traffic.
JON FOUST: Which made our
gameplay a little bit longer.
So that was pretty cool.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
so much the better, right?
That could've lasted
for three hours
and it would've been great.
So what are we talking
about in this episode?
JON FOUST: Sure,
so in this episode,
we'll be talking to
Rory Petty, product
manager for Stackdriver.
We're going to talk about the
new things Stackdriver has
to offer, as well as some
helpful tips from a product
manager himself.
And we will also get into our
Question of the Week, which
will help you decide whether you
should use Apps Script or App
Maker when you're trying
to build out your app.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Ooh,
sounds like a good episode
full of learning things.
JON FOUST: And I think
our listeners will really
be excited about the
cool things that we
have in store for this week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You want to kick
things off, Mark?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, absolutely.
Well, I think the coolest thing
that I have found this week
is we're just coming off
of KubeCon in Barcelona,
and we know that some
of our colleagues went.
One of our co-hosts,
Michelle was at KubeCon.
I believe she was speaking.
And one of the best things
that has come out of at KubeCon
is everything.
So if you didn't get
a chance to make it,
there's tons of
content on YouTube.
So we'll have a link
down in the show notes
talking about, well,
actually just linking
to all the different
talks that happened there.
There was a big-- this is
the five-year anniversary
of Kubernetes, so great on them.
And of course there's
a lot of cool content
around the changes they're
making, new additions.
And I think that the
Kubernetes Podcast also
does a good job of talking
about and recapping
all the great happenings.
JON FOUST: Yeah,
those guys are great.
I guess, for me, another
cool thing that I noticed
is, on my commute
to work yesterday,
I noticed that there are new
terminals for your smart device
where you can use Google
Pay to actually pay your way
through your turnstiles.
Which is kind of
cool because we're
advancing in the technology.
Pretty soon, we'll
have flying cars.
But you can also
use Google Assistant
to help you plan your commute.
So you can ask your Google
Assistant, hey, Google,
how long will it take
me to get to work,
or what is the fastest
way for me to get to work?
And Google Assistant
will readily help you.
So it's pretty good to
help, especially when
you're going through a
large transportation hub
and you want to know which
train you should take
and what's the fastest way.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, you
know, I hadn't considered that,
but when we are
in our flying cars
and then we had to
stop at a tollbooth,
I guess the whole idea of having
to throw change into a bucket
just wouldn't quite resonate
with our cars and the ability
to kind of zoom off.
[CHANGE CLINKING, ENGINE
BUZZING]
JON FOUST: Right,
and I mean, granted,
I did like working on my jump
shot when throwing change.
But I mean, let's
just be serious,
we're advancing to a time
where, pretty soon, we'll
have flying jet packs.
[SCI-FI STROBING SOUND EFFECT]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, I
mean, who needs the cars?
We'll just go straight
for teleportation.
[DIGITAL WHISTLING SOUND EFFECT]
Let's just go all the way.
JON FOUST: Oh, yeah.
Or we can do just
like "Futurama,"
and have those little tubes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: The
pneumatic tube system?
[WHOOSING, CLICKING SOUND
EFFECT]
JON FOUST: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That
seems so backwards for me.
Like is that really futuristic?
Because we've had those tubes
since at least decades ago,
for mail.
And something about just
shoving people in tubes,
I don't know if--
I think I'll take the jet packs.
JON FOUST: You know what
always got me about those shows
is, when you go into the
tube, you're upright,
but when you come out of the
tube, you're also upright.
So at what point in the
tube do you flip around?
[MYSTERIOUS MUSICAL ARPEGGIO
PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
That is a plot hole.
I demand an email
from the creators
explaining how this works.
But you know what, I get
the feeling that they will
have better things to work on.
JON FOUST: Right.
And another cool thing that
our team has been really
talking about in chat
was the early preview
for AR on Google Maps.
It was shown off at Google
I/O, where you can actually
put your Pixel phone in
AR mode while navigating,
and it will help you with
turn-by-turn directions,
on-screen.
So there's no second-guessing
the direction you're going in,
especially when you
can see the landmarks.
And Google Maps will
actually show you
which landmark
you're looking at,
which direction
you need to turn,
you need to face,
and how far you need to actually
walk, which is kind of awesome.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, I mean, we're not
at those flying cars
yet, but I think anything
that improves the
driving experience,
especially using
kind of the-- it's
a good showcase of how AR can
really be used in real life
to say, hey, look, let's
make our lives better,
let's make things easier.
JON FOUST: Cool.
So that'll do it for the
Cool Things of the Week.
So let's get right
into it with Rory
and talk about the cool things
that Stackdriver has to offer.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Sounds good.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, thanks so much
for joining us, Rory.
Hey, why don't you tell us a
little bit about who you are
and what you do at Google?
RORY PETTY: Yeah, my
name is Rory Petty.
I'm a PM-- a product manager--
on Stackdriver.
And a lot of people aren't
familiar with the Stackdriver
brand name, but that's basically
the brand name that encompasses
the suite of monitoring,
observability,
and logging tools
for Google Cloud.
So for example,
within Stackdriver,
there is a tool for
monitoring, like I said,
logging, and then
also our APM tools,
which are Application
Performance Management tools.
So that includes things like
Debugger, Trace, Profiler,
so really this
kind of whole suite
of tools that lets
you understand
how your website or your
application is performing.
So I like to kind
of liken it back
to the dashboard in your car.
If you're driving
down the highway,
the dashboard tells
you how fast you're
going, if your engine's
about to overheat,
are you about to run out of gas.
And so, in the same way,
the Stackdriver suite,
when you have it hooked up
to your mobile application,
your website, your
e-commerce store, whatever,
it provides you those
critical insights
into how your service
or site is performing.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So what's
your role within the program
manager for Stackdriver?
What does that kind of entail?
RORY PETTY: Product manager.
Maybe I misspoke.
So basically I work on product
for Stackdriver monitoring.
So I work on the
core monitoring APIs,
I work on query notation, which
is a new feature that we have
in Alpha right now,
which I can talk
about more in a little bit.
I also work on our
systems that handle
alerting and
notifications, kind of how
you are able to tell the system,
hey, alert me and notify me
if something's going
wrong with my system.
That's kind of my focus area.
JON FOUST: Gotcha.
So that sounds
really interesting,
because I just started using
Stackdriver myself recently,
because like many
of our developers,
they just want to build
the solution right away.
But when things go wacky or
when things are uploaded,
they don't really
actually have the time
to follow up and
actually monitor
and actually get these alerts.
So I recently just
started using alerts
for when my Noogler project goes
off, whenever anything fails.
So can you tell our
listeners a little bit more
about the type of alerts
that you actually get.
RORY PETTY: Sure.
So there's kind of
a variety of alerts
that you can set up with
the Stackdriver Monitoring.
So I'll start out by
saying that, in terms
of all the Google Cloud
Services that are out there,
Stackdriver supports them--
Stackdriver
Monitoring and Logging
supports them out of the box.
So for example, if you spin
up a new compute instance,
a new compute VM, or you spin
up an App Engine instance,
all that kind of stuff,
they automatically start
sending metrics and logs
to Stackdriver for you.
So you really, in
most cases, for a VM,
you might have to install an
agent or a couple other things.
But you're basically getting
out-of-the-box metrics
and logs.
And so I like to think
about it in a couple stages.
First is I'm receiving this kind
of telemetry data from my VM,
from my application.
Just let me look at the
data and understand it.
So that could be I'm looking at
CPU usage or network latency.
It could be something
more complicated.
If I've created
SLOs for my service.
But basically you're
getting this data,
you're kind of
figuring out what's
the steady state of
your system, and then
what's the state of
your system where
it's going to start to degrade?
So for example, if your
CPU is at 100% on the VM
and you can't accept
new incoming requests,
or if you run out
of storage, or any
of the million different
things that could happen.
So that's where
alerts come into play.
It's where you say, OK, I
know what the correct state
of my system should be.
And if certain
metrics start to go
past these certain
thresholds, then
alert me, because I should come
back and take a look at it,
and I should spin
up new servers,
or I should figure out
if a bug was deployed,
whatever the case may be.
So with alerts, there's a
couple of different approaches.
The first is you can
alert on metrics.
So these would be
GCP service metrics
that the services send-- again,
App Engine, GCE, GKE, whatever.
It can also be custom metrics.
So for example, say, I
have an e-commerce store,
every time someone
checks out, I may
want to write a metric
to Stackdriver to say
a checkout just happened.
So from that, later, I can
visualize these metrics.
Like I could have a dashboard
of the number of checkouts
per day or per hour.
I could do other kind
of analysis or math
on that to tell me
what's the amount of time
that it takes between
checkouts, or how frequently are
my high-value customers checking
out, all that kind of stuff.
Another approach
that you can take,
if you've read the
Google SRE book,
it draws this distinction
between white-box monitoring
and black-box monitoring.
So white-box monitoring is
when your service or system
omits metrics.
Like your VM is
constantly sending CPU
usage metrics, network
metrics, whatever.
But a black box is
literally just that.
You basically say, I don't know
the contents of this system,
but I'm going to ping it
and say, hey, are you alive,
are you working?
So basically, in
Stackdriver, you
can go in and create what's
called an uptime check.
And Google's HTTP prober service
that we run globally, it's
also the same
service that Google
uses to black-box monitor
its own internal tools
and services.
It can basically
send an HTTP request
to a URL endpoint for your
app, and not only say,
hey, are you up, but
it can actually check
the contents of the response.
So I'm going to hit
the shopping cart URL
endpoint of my
e-commerce service,
and I'm going to
check the response
to say, OK, am I getting
certain HTML form fields back,
am I getting certain values?
So you can kind of do--
it's basically like a next-order
set of checks to make sure
that your service is healthy.
And so again, going
back to the SRE book,
it kind of has
this recommendation
that, for an advanced
monitoring practice,
you should really use both.
You should have alerts set up
on the white-box metrics that
are being exported
by your service,
and then you should also have
these black-box programmers
that are probing the health
and liveliness of your service
as well.
JON FOUST: Sounds awesome.
One thing that you said that
I think our listeners will
be interested in
hearing about is you
used the word,
monitoring, quite a bit.
And I'm pretty sure
that Stackdriver
has some type of monitoring
UI or some visuals
that we can actually help
trace our logs and everything.
So can you talk more about that?
RORY PETTY: Basically,
in Google Cloud console,
if you go into that
left nav that slides out
and has a million options,
there's a Stackdriver section.
And again, that is broken
out into the core Stackdriver
services of Monitoring, Logging,
and then the other APM tools--
Trace Profiler, Debugger.
So Monitoring specifically,
when you go into Monitoring,
it will first ask you
to create a workspace.
And the reason that we have
this workspace construct
is that, oftentimes, people want
to monitor one or more projects
of theirs in Google Cloud.
So for example, you
can imagine a scenario
where I work at a company
and I'm a sysadmin,
or I'm an SRE, or a developer,
or whatever the case is.
And we have-- our
website could be
an e-commerce provider,
like Target.com
or something like that,
but it's probably,
at a certain scale, divided
across multiple projects.
So you might have a front
end for the website that's
being driven by services
out of one project,
you might have a shopping cart
or payment gateway service
that runs in another project.
So long story short,
you want to monitor
all of these kind of
in the same place.
And so a workspace, you
can put multiple projects
into a workspace that can
give you visibility across all
of them at the same time.
So Jon, going back
to your question,
once you go into the
Stackdriver Monitoring section,
there's a variety of
things you can do.
One is that there's this
section called Resources,
where we actually create
out-of-the-box dashboards
for you, for a variety
of common resources.
So that could be Cloud Storage,
VM instances, App Engine,
Google Kubernetes
Engine, all of those.
So you actually don't have
to do a lot of configuration
out of the box.
For example, say, let's select
one of our GCE VM instances.
We're going to give
you CPU usage, memory
usage, uptime check latency.
We're going to show you events
related to that particular VM,
whether you have uptime checks
configured, what's the network
traffic look like?
So a lot of people
are worried about, oh,
is it complicated to set up
and start using Stackdriver?
Again, for a variety of use
cases, it's pretty simple,
and kind of just
works out of the box.
Now, if you have more
complicated needs,
more advanced needs,
you want to set up
your own dashboards, that
is certainly a functionality
that we support.
So you can go in, create a
custom dashboard, and say,
I want to create
a dashboard that
tracks the health of my
shopping cart service
for my e-commerce website.
So you can do a variety
of charts and graphs that,
again, measure any metric
that that service exports.
So that, again, could be CPU
disk, memory, network, custom
metrics that you're writing.
It's really configurable
however you want.
Stackdriver also just
recently launched
a new product called service
monitoring that basically
went into alpha at Google
Cloud Next in San Francisco
back in April.
So the idea behind that is that,
let's say you're running a GKE
cluster, there is an open-source
project called Istio which is
basically software
that helps you define--
basically, a mesh for
your microservices.
So it's everything
from the control plane
to metrics to how the
services talk to each other,
authenticate.
Istio handles all of that.
And so the cool
thing is that Istio
borrows a lot of
architecture from how
Google manages its services
and microservices internally.
And so Istio, once you
configure it out of the box,
will give you metrics
and traces and a variety
of other telemetry that you
can use to better understand
your system.
And so Service
Monitoring not only
makes it easy to
configure all of that.
You can actually see it visually
in this kind of typology graph.
So you can imagine,
like in Google Maps,
a visual map of these are where
different points of interest
or locations are on the map.
Stackdriver Service
Monitoring will actually
show you a visual map of
your entire microservice
architecture.
It'll show you where
all the VMs are,
who's talking to what, how
much traffic, and like how
many queries per second are
going between various instances
and endpoints.
It's pretty cool.
We're hoping to get to a public
beta of it later in the year.
We don't have a
definitive timeline yet
but I think it's something
that a lot of people
will be very excited
to work with.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So I mean, that's
a pretty deep dive on
a lot of the monitoring
side of things at Stackdriver.
But there's a lot more to it.
You mentioned logging
a little bit earlier,
but you also kind of mentioned
a collection of other tools.
And you were talking
about the SRE book.
Would you say that
maybe Stackdriver
is a little bit more
designed as a set of tools
to support this SRE cycle?
RORY PETTY: So it's interesting.
There's no one true way to
kind of monitor and maintain
your systems.
Obviously, Google has
like a very specific point
of view with the SRE book.
But the point of the
Stackdriver suite
of tools, which, again, to your
point, is not just monitoring--
is logging and a
variety of other tools--
is to really meet
customers where they're at.
We have baked some of
the best SRE principles
into the Stackdriver tools.
But if that's not part
of your DevOps practice,
then we want the tools to
still be useful to you.
So for example,
there are still a lot
of companies or
development organizations
that the primary way that
they understand and debug
their systems is through logs.
So they'll log all these
different important touchpoints
within their code.
If there are errors,
they'll dump stack traces.
They'll dump a variety
of other information.
And so their developers are
both watching logs in real time,
and they're also creating
alerts on their logs.
So that's actually
another interesting point
that you brought up, Mark,
which is that Stackdriver
is a set of different
tools, but there
are a lot of horizontal
journeys and capabilities
that tie all the tools together.
So for example, let's say that
I'm logging my Java application
to use Stackdriver login.
And let's say that every
time someone checks out
in my e-commerce shop,
I write a log entry.
Or every time that someone
encounters a problem,
I write a log entry that's
an error, an exception,
or that kind of thing.
You can actually create what's
called a logs-based metric
in logging, which
basically says,
every time this kind
of log entry happens--
I mean, you can do simple
matching against the log entry.
You can match on
like a regex and say
if the log entry contains
these kind of words or phrases
or matches against
this regex, basically
write a data point as
part of a time series.
And then that time series
that is created from the log--
again, this log-based metric,
you can do all kinds of things
with.
You can visualize
it on a dashboard.
You can create an
alert off of it.
So while the products
are separate,
they are kind of
intimately tied together
in terms of how
you would use them
as part of a DevOps practice.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So somebody
could come in and maybe just
say, all right, I have
everything kind of figured out
on my side, but I want some
nice dashboard for monitoring.
Stackdriver could
kind of offer that
through the monitoring service
and the dashboards that
are built in or the ones
that you can customize.
But if you're kind of
starting from scratch,
maybe you can adopt a lot of
the different Stackdriver tools
and have that almost
Google-centric SRE idea, right?
RORY PETTY: Yeah, very much so.
Like we want the tools
to meet your needs.
So if you just want to
use monitoring or logging,
that's fine.
But you really get the
most value out of the suite
the more tools that you use.
So for example, you might
start by just configuring,
monitoring, and
logging, but then you'll
see a lot of added value if
you add in Trace or Debugger
or Profiler.
Again, at the end
of the day, it all
goes back to how can we
help you debug issues
that you're having
in your system,
and how can we help you
understand your system.
So logging and monitoring
are very much kind
of like the bedrock of that
practice but as an industry.
And it's not just Google.
Like there are a variety
of other cloud providers
and other kind of service
providers in the market that
provide APM tools, Trace,
Profiler-- that kind of stuff.
So what we're realizing
as an industry
is that logging and monitoring
are great for a lot of things.
They're not always the best
tool to debug really complicated
issues.
And so that's where, again, some
of these second-order tools,
like the APM tools,
come into play.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So we've actually
talked about a shocking amount
in a short period of time,
way more than from
the days I remember
of just kind of, like
you said, var dumping out
a bunch of stuff and checking
for what I wanted to grab.
There's been a lot
of people looking
to kind of adopt Stackdriver.
Obviously, it has a
lot of power behind it.
And I think one of
the more recent tools
that has come out to help that
is the Stackdriver Sandbox.
Can you talk a little
bit more about what
that is, what its aim is,
and how people can use it?
RORY PETTY: Yeah.
Stackdriver Sandbox
is a cool project
that has just come out
of Google recently,
where one of the
things that we find
is that people want
to better understand
how monitoring and logging
and APM tools like Stackdriver
work, but they're kind
of afraid to set them up
on their production environment.
Like they don't want to
cause any disruption,
and they kind of want to just
kick the tires in a safe way,
learn how the products work,
learn them a little bit better,
and then figure
out kind of what's
their on-ramp to implementing
them as part of their DevOps
practice.
And so, basically, the
Stackdriver Sandbox
gives you a really easy way
with, like, essentially one
script that you just run.
And it will configure an entire
sandbox or test Stackdriver
environment for you, where
you can kind of spin up
any kind of test
VMs that you want,
spin up any Kubernetes clusters.
You could create, effectively,
like a whole mirror
of your staging or
production systems there
but in a safe environment
that, once you're done with it,
you can tear down.
And you don't have to worry
about you accidentally
left something running, and
you're incurring billing
and all of that.
So it's a very
cost-effective and safe way
to better understand
the whole suite of tools
that Stackdriver provides.
JON FOUST: That's awesome.
And you mentioned that
this is relatively new.
And you mentioned a couple times
that a couple of the products
are going into alpha and beta.
Can you tell us
a little bit more
about what the roadmap for
Stackdriver's looking like?
RORY PETTY: Sure, yeah.
So one thing I would say
is I would go check out
a lot of the announcements that
we just made in April at Google
Cloud Next in San Francisco.
All of the Stackdriver talks
are available on YouTube.
I think one of the
conference websites
is like cloudonair.google.com.
Or basically, if you Google for
like GCP Next and Cloud OnAir,
there's a huge list
of the various talks
that cover Stackdriver and
DevOps and all of that.
But a couple of things
that we announced.
One is that our
profiler tool went GA.
So we haven't talked
about Profiler a lot yet,
but it's also a really
cool tool to understand
the performance of your system.
So basically, what it does
is you basically include
a library in your software and
do some basic configuration.
And what it will do
is as your service
is running, it will periodically
pull your CPU usage,
pull your memory usage.
And then, basically, it
profiles your call stack
of your running
application, and it
will tell you, percentage-wise,
where you spend the most time.
So for example,
you could imagine
you have a web server that
is receiving a request
and adding an item
to a shopping cart.
And so in the Profiler, you
might go in and say, OK,
why is this one URL
endpoint, this API
handler for the shopping cart--
why is it taking so
long because it's
taking like five
seconds, on average,
to add an item to
the shopping cart.
So you go in in Profiler,
and you look at it.
And you can clearly see, oh,
this one function or this one
method--
say, for example like a
JSON deserialization method
or something like that--
this is actually taking
up 90% of the time
of my total response time.
So as a developer,
you're able to say,
oh, I need to go in and
optimize this function,
I need to improve my code--
a variety of things.
So it's basically a tool
for developers that really
lets them optimize their code.
And what we've
seen in practice is
when big companies use
it, not only are they
able to improve the
performance of their code,
but that translates
back into not just
benefits for their users,
but, actually, benefits
for their cloud spend.
So again, the less time
you're spinning CPU cycles,
you might be able to save
money on your compute cost
or the amount of memory that
you need for a particular VM
instance.
So it can be one of
those cases where
a little bit of time investment
there can actually save you
a large amount of money or
a user satisfaction in terms
of real-world benefits.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I think that for the Cloud
OnAir that you were mentioning,
if people can go to the Google
Cloud Platform YouTube channel,
if you search Stackdriver
there, you'll actually
see a fair amount of content.
We've got the series
called Stack Doctor, where
we talk about some of the best
practices in getting started
with Stackdriver as well
as a bunch of webinars
with Cloud OnAir, where we'll
talk about different areas.
I think was a recent
one on the Profiler,
for instance, and kind
of how those things work
and kind of stepping into it.
I think there's a lot
of resources out there
for, hopefully, people to
learn more about Stackdriver
because a lot of cases, it's not
just going to be plug and play.
You're going to have to
do a fair amount of work
integrating it.
But the more you integrate
it and kind of the more you
lean into it, like
you just said,
the more rewards you'll see.
RORY PETTY: Yeah.
And I think part of the
value of Stackdriver,
too, is that it provides
a lot of these tools
and services across the whole
spectrum of DevOps needs.
So for example,
one thing that we
see a lot of times talking to
customers that are new to GCP--
they might have one tool
or service provider that
just does logging or another
tool that does monitoring,
another tool that does Trace or
Profiler-- that kind of thing.
And obviously, we want
customers to use the right tools
based on what their needs are.
But there is a value in using
a single suite of tools that
are all designed
to work together
and can kind of get you closer
to that single pane of glass
that is so often talked about in
the DevOps community of what's
a single place that
I can go, and I
can see all the telemetry.
And I can basically have a
God's eye view of my system.
I can see my logs, my metrics,
my traces, all the telemetry
all together.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
With that being
said, what would you say your
favorite piece of Stackdriver
is?
RORY PETTY: That's tough.
I mean, I'm a little
biased because I
work on the monitoring tool.
So I think that there's a lot of
value that monitoring provides.
I also think that there's a
lot of value in our APM tools.
So Trace is
particularly interesting
because, again, if you have
kind of a service-based
architecture, you can
imagine a scenario-- again,
we'll use the shopping
cart scenario-- where
customer clicks Add to Cart.
But behind the scenes,
there might actually
be tens of different services
that talk to each other.
So the web server has to call
the currency conversion service
to convert from
dollars to euros,
and then it has to call the
warehouse inventory system,
like is this item
still in stock.
You could imagine just
one simple web request
having to cascade into all
these different internal service
calls.
And so that's where using
traditional tools like logging
and debugging-- it can be
really difficult to figure out
what's gone wrong or where
the performance problem is
because you might be looking
at hundreds of log entries
across tens of
different services.
So what Trace does is it gives
you this kind of waterfall view
that shows you all of
the internal service
requests stitched together, so
you can very quickly and easily
visually see what's taking
the most time in all
of these service requests, which
internal request has the most
latency and is affecting the
performance of my system.
So I think Trace is a really
cool tool in that regard.
Also, a tool that
doesn't get as much
love, but I think is super
powerful, is Debugger.
And so many people are familiar
with debuggers in the context
of developing your application.
So you're writing code.
You're testing it.
It's not quite working right,
so you put a breakpoint
in your code, and then you click
a button in your website, app,
whatever.
And then, basically,
when it reaches
that point in your code,
execution will pause.
And you can see, basically,
all of the context
of what's going on in your
call stack at that point.
So you can see what are the
value of different variables.
You can see a whole
variety of things.
So again, this is a very common
workflow for a developer.
What's hard is that
when you're running
an application in production,
you can't effectively
pause the code.
If a customer is
having an issue,
I can't pause the
code, which pauses
execution for that customer
or all the customers.
But what's kind of
cool and magical
is that if you configure
your website or application
to work with
Stackdriver Debugger,
it will effectively
take snapshots
of the internal state
of your application
such that you can
actually link your code.
So if your code is in GitHub
or Google source repositories
or whatever, you can actually
set breakpoints in your code,
and you can view
at that breakpoint
the context of live
production traffic with a zero
performance hit to your actual
running web application.
So it's pretty magical.
It basically lets you
debug production code
on the fly with no
performance hit.
Also, another capability
that it has is you
can basically use it to insert
log lines into production code.
So I mean, as developers, how
many times has this happened,
where you have an application,
you roll out some new code,
and there's a bug, or it's
not performing like it should?
So you say, OK, how can I
figure out what's going wrong?
So you go back to your code.
You add a bunch more log lines.
You add a bunch more logging.
Now you have to redeploy
your entire application just
to see in your logs the state
of things, what's happening,
what's gone wrong.
And so where that
becomes really tricky
is that you've now
made it 10 times harder
to isolate the actual issue
because when you redeploy
your code, there's a huge
other variety of variables that
could change, things that could
go wrong, that kind of thing.
So basically, without
doing a new code deploy,
Debugger allows you
to insert log lines
into live running code to
better understand and diagnose
and debug a problem.
So I hope I did it justice
through that explanation.
It's a really cool tool.
And frankly, there are
not very many other tools
like that on the market
that can do live production
debugging with basically
zero performance impact.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I mean, I think that's a
dream for a lot of people.
But if I understood
you correctly,
your favorite part
about Stackdriver
is basically all of Stackdriver.
RORY PETTY: Yeah.
I feel like I kind of
dodged your question
and talked about everything.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, it's cool.
There's a lot of good
stuff in there, right?
RORY PETTY: Yes.
Yes.
It's hard to pick favorites.
And again, I think
it goes back to what
I think is a common
misunderstanding, that you
should really think
of Stackdriver
as separate products.
I mean, there is, again, logging
and monitoring and all of that.
But they really are
meant to work together
as a suite of tools.
So don't think of logging as a
hammer and monitoring as a saw.
Think of it as these are all
the tools in a toolbox that I'm
using to repair my house,
build a house, whatever
your hacky analogy is there.
But they really are a suite of
tools meant to work together.
JON FOUST: Your explanation
was spot-on for me
because I've actually used it in
the same exact scenario, where
I needed to test something, and
I was working with a teammate.
So we were able
to not only throw
in log lines in the
middle of our code
without having to
actually change anything.
And using the Debugger, we
found several edge cases
that we definitely missed.
And we have an
internal project that I
worked on that is
currently in production
and can be used
internally by googlers.
And it was pretty awesome using
Stackdriver for the first time
because I wouldn't have
actually found those edge
cases in that scenario.
I'm actually kind of curious if
there are any really impressive
use cases that you've heard
any of our customers using
or any developers
that you've met.
I'm not sure if you can
touch on that a little bit.
RORY PETTY: Again, some of these
are on the GCP YouTube channel.
But this year at Next, we
had quite a few sessions
that were kind of
co-led with customers.
So Samsung did a
session on how they
use Stackdriver to
monitor the performance
of a lot of their systems.
Obviously, Samsung is a huge
electronics conglomerate,
so they have a huge variety
of web-based services
that they have to
run and maintain.
So they talked about
how they use Stackdriver
to calculate SLOs for their
services, crack error budgets,
things like that.
So, yeah, there were quite
a few different companies
kind of at that scale
that are using Stackdriver
and have done public talks.
So I would highly
recommend checking out
the YouTube channel.
There were a lot of good
talks where it's not
just the Stackdriver team
giving you a sales pitch
or telling you to
use Stackdriver.
It's, I think, a lot
more powerful when
you hear these are customers
that are having success
with the product
that are able to use
it to meet their needs
at a very large scale.
I think that's where the
rubber meets the road,
and you can kind of see the
real value of the product.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
So we're running a
little short on time,
but I just wanted to
give you the opportunity
to speak on anything
that we might have missed
or anything you want to mention
before we wrap things up.
RORY PETTY: Yeah.
I would just say
that while there
are a lot of products in
the Stackdriver suite,
I think it's not
something to be afraid of.
I mean, whether you're
using the Sandbox
or whether you're just
creating a test environment,
it's really easy just to
start using Stackdriver
to kick the tires on it.
Then like I mentioned, if
you go to the Stackdriver
documentation, if you search
for the list of metrics,
you can see across all the
different GCP services.
Pretty much all of them
are already integrated out
of the box with Stackdriver.
So our goal is to be the best
set of DevOps tools for Google
Cloud, so it's really easy
to start using Stackdriver
and to get value out of the box
without configuring anything.
I will also say that
while our primary focus is
on Google Cloud, we do
support other clouds.
We are a multi-cloud service.
So we do our Logging and
Monitoring metrics support AWS.
So if you still
primarily are on AWS,
or maybe you have a hybrid
multi-cloud architecture,
we definitely support
that functionality.
We also have a new
feature we've rolled out
with a partner called Blue
Medora, where they have
another agent that
you can install
that not only supports
other clouds like Azure,
it supports a wide
variety of use cases.
It could be Windows
VMs, a huge number,
like hundreds of different open
source products and services.
So the central point is that
whatever kind of infrastructure
you're running, whether
it's on prem, in the cloud,
some kind of hybrid thereof--
Windows, Linux, monolithic
apps, microservices--
Stackdriver will
support your use case
and help give you observability
into your systems.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Very cool.
Well, thanks so much for
joining us, Rory, and telling us
a lot about--
I think a whole bunch
about-- the different tools
that are inside of Stackdriver.
And then I think that for people
who are interested, hopefully,
there's a lot of tools out
there for them to kind of get
learning pretty quickly.
RORY PETTY: Yeah.
I would say check out the
Stackdriver YouTube channel
along with the GCP channel.
There's a lot of great
content on there.
One of our DevOps
engineers, Yuri,
has a YouTube channel or
show called Stack Doctor.
So that's S-T-A-C-K doctor.
And he digs into a lot of the
finer points of Stackdriver.
He'll show you how to
configure various things,
how to do kind of
advanced use cases.
That's really good content.
And then also, feel
free to follow our blog.
We have new product
announcements there.
We post a lot of best
practices there, really
getting into a
lot of the details
about how to best configure
your alert policies,
how to best configure
your logging setup.
And so there is a lot
of content out there
for people that are
interested in how
to structure their DevOps
practice on Google Cloud
and beyond.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
Mark and I would like to
thank Rory for joining us.
And Rory, once again,
it's been a pleasure.
RORY PETTY: Yeah.
Thanks, guys.
Thanks for having me.
JON FOUST: Well, thanks again
for helping our listeners
understand the cool
things that you
could do with Stackdriver
and the new features
and new announcement that
recently just come out.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
There's always a lot of
things on the roadmap.
And Stackdriver is such a
broad set of different tools,
like we talked about.
I think that you can definitely
find something in there
that you can integrate
with your app to,
hopefully, increase
the observability
or just make life
a little easier.
JON FOUST: Right.
And I know that it's made
my life quite a bit easier,
especially when I've actually
deployed my application,
and I really need to debug
it, but on the local level,
I just don't really
want to do it.
I'd much rather do it while
my app is running the cloud.
So let's get into our
question of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I think you've seen a blog post
that probably sparked this,
but I guess our
question is, how do you
decide between Apps
Script and App Maker
when you actually want to
build out your application?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
And just like you
mentioned, there
is a blog post
that kind of dives
into the details about
why you might choose one
over the other.
They're both great tools
to create and customize
the experience for users on
the G Suite side of things.
But there's a couple
of key differences.
And when you're trying
to decide between them,
the important things
to keep in mind
are how much you want to rely
on the G Suite experience,
or do you want to build
a custom user interface?
Are you just kind of adding
additional functionality, which
is something that Apps
Script is great for?
It's based on JavaScript.
You're able to go in and
kind of say, OK, well, users
using the sheet.
Let me add some custom
JavaScript functionality
so that when they do this, I
can automate this task for them.
Or are you looking to build
a self-contained experience,
where you have full access,
and you can hook it up
to Cloud SQL, so
you can actually
back it with a full database
and then kind of create
this curated content for them?
That's much more of what
App Maker should be.
So you kind of have that
choice between the two of them.
Again, the blog post kind of
asks a couple of questions
and tells you why you might
consider one over the other.
But either way, ultimately,
people, especially we
at Google--
but I think a lot
of businesses--
spend a lot of time in
G Suite whether it's
Docs or Sheets or whatever.
There's so much
going on in there.
Anything you can do around
automating or making
tasks easier in there or adding
additional functionality--
both of them are great
ways to do that and really
just save time or really kind
of add surprising features.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
I probably now will
look at this blog post
because I definitely do a lot of
application design and creation
around the cool gaming
things that I work on.
And it'd be kind of cool to
see the difference between App
Maker and Apps
Script personally.
But also, it'll help me make
the decision on which I should
probably use for
my application just
to improve that
production process.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I mean, absolutely.
I do a tremendous amount
of spreadsheet work.
And every time I put
something into a spreadsheet,
if I have to do it more
than like five or six times,
I have to ask myself,
is this something easier
that I can actually
just build a script for,
which is always going to
be a trade-off depending
on exactly how much time
do you want to invest
in making it reusable.
But every spreadsheet and
some docs that I work on,
it's just like I want a
script to help me with this.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
So Mark, what will you
be doing pretty soon?
What are you getting into?
Any travel you got planned?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I'm
not a big traveler,
but I will be going to New York.
Hopefully, we can maybe sit down
and play some Smash Brothers
while I'm out there.
I think you'll be
in town, right?
JON FOUST: So for
me, I'll be in town.
And I'll be attending
Games for Change,
which is going to be awesome.
This is my first
Games for Change,
and I'm real excited to go.
For those of you that do
not know, Games for Change
is, essentially, a conference
that brings game developers who
are using games as a platform
to empower social impact
and educate those
in the actual power
behind games because
a lot of people
don't really know how
much influence games have.
And it's great for
kids because games
are a really big, pivotal
part of your childhood
for most children in
some way, some fashion.
And it doesn't actually
have to be video games.
But games in general
is a very big platform
because it brings up
a lot of social issues
and can help educate
people on biases.
So it'd be great to actually
see how a lot of developers
are actually using these games
to make a conscious effort
to make things better.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
It's really cool to see all
of the smaller indie game
studios or even just
individual people
who are creating
games to kind of show
not only some of the
social issues that exist,
but also to help enable
people to kind of create
their own games.
Or I think we've seen
a couple of games
that try to take
machine learning
and explain that in a much
more approachable way.
And I think there's
a wide variety.
Whether it's teaching people
about STEM technologies
or whether it's more on the
social and cultural issue
sides, I think
that games are just
a different kind of medium for
people to actually approach
the education world with.
Yeah.
So I think it's like the 15th
or 16th summit they've had,
so I'm sure there's
a lot of cool things
that have changed
over the past decade.
So it's really great to see
a lot of people kind of come
into the same place and
talk about all the things
that they're working on and
all the ways to enable people.
JON FOUST: And I'm glad that
I'm currently working in games
and also trying to make a
conscious effort to help
developers and users
all over the world.
Well that'll wrap
things up for us
on this episode of the Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
Thank you for listening,
and we'll see you next week.
Thanks, Mark.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Thanks, Jon.
We'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JON FOUST: We don't
have to do this.
That's what the great
editors are for.
You guys are awesome.
[CHIME]
[LAUGHS]